I'm gonna start this right out with some
phrases and props if you worked on the
audio mixing and/or editing in blood or
which good job seriously the audio is
what sucks you in it was [ __ ] got real
sound control alright props over time to
review
[Music]
Blair Witch to Blair which is a sequel
to the 1999 Godfather of found-footage
movies the Blair Witch Project not
really a second one because everyone in
its own meta way takes place outside
that movie in our own world it's keeping
it vague for you this footage is found
put up on YouTube this dude's like hey
my sisters lost in those woods I think
that's her we gotta go find her so a
crew of people go to the woods of
Burkittsville living it's Maryland and
they're looking for a sister how bad
shits gonna happen and starting it off I
want to let you know right now this
movie takes a bit to get going yes so
did the original Blair Witch Project yes
so does every other found footage movie
worth its salt and it's a negative as
you stand here and say it but is it
really a negative because it seems every
found footage movie that just starts out
trying to just hammer it overhead
alright exciting [ __ ] those are the dumb
ones those are the ones that you just
don't give a [ __ ] about you forget about
right when you leave the movie theater
the ones that last are the ones that
take time to build so hey there you go
props movie for doing the long game this
movie has more than a few creepy parts
yes it also has more than a few familiar
parts also you look at a lot of the
situational circumstance and this woman
compared to the Blair Witch Project it's
the same thing I mean the same [ __ ]
happens however I rolled with that with
create I rolled with that with the force
awakens the Blair Witch is not going to
be where I draw the line I'm like no
more because I know the formula at this
point the formula is when you have a
movie that set up a franchise or a genre
and it's been so many years between that
movie and this sequel that you want to
do you're going to make the sequel echo
a lot of things from before to let the
audience know hey yeah we didn't forget
we know why you love us here you go
here's some familiar stuff well I don't
think Blair Witch is setting up for a
sequel it's kind of a one-shot pony I
think unless they try to make it oh god
they're going to aren't they to do that
it is playing it safe showing you the
familiar but it also does work to give
you an enjoyable enough time what I
liked about this movie is what I said
before is the audio some about when the
creepy things start happening the audio
alone draws you in you need to watch it
in theatres in that respect or at least
if you have a 5.1 surround system to
watch it there you're fine if you want
to watch it in your house but if you're
watching on TV you're not going to get
that effect you're not going to hear the
twig snap behind you you're not going to
hear the whisper of the kid or person or
ghost or whatever to the right that's
the creepy engrossing that's when the
movie draws you in you're like oh my god
I'm in the wood
and I'm gonna die that's what this movie
did very well also I like the setting I
mean the woods in this movie look a lot
thicker there's a lot more engrossing a
lot more claustrophobic as much as this
movie had the slow build building up to
it when it hit when the [ __ ] starts to
go down the [ __ ] starts to go down and
it feels really threatening for its part
until it starts showing too much what I
mean by that is the original Blair Witch
Project had subtlety you didn't see a
lodge because they didn't have the
budget to show you like what are the
dues just ends up not there anymore it's
just one morning he's gone I believe
from what I remember I saw the movie
once in theaters the reason I didn't see
it again because the last 5 10 15
minutes of the Blair Witch Project is
the creepiest ending of anything I've
ever seen ever so we only saw the movie
once you'll be a completely different
thing now I mean I could watch now
you're like why was I so freaked out but
at the time scared the piss out of it
the point is the original Blair Witch
Project to do just vanish this and this
one they have to show you what happened
to me when people start dropping like
flies and they do the movie has to show
you how it happens and what happened to
them I was thinking to be a lot creepier
if just people just started just
disappearing you don't know where they
went but their column for their names
and before you know it it's like where
did the other person guys it that kind
of stuff creeps me out more cuz it makes
you feel more real and the next time
you're camping with your friends used to
look around you like are they all here
that's how the movie really invades your
reality is when they make things more
subtle so you can project yourself into
there that's what subtlety allows the
audience to do this movie though subtle
in parts wasn't as subtle it had to show
you a lot of stuff however again with
the end of this movie I was at the edge
of my seat I mean it was all going down
people are running people are scared I'm
just like I'm they're biting my nails in
true Blair Witch Project Blair Witch
fashion because in the end Blair Witch
does its part to carry the torch of the
first Blair Witch Project it's also the
greatest marketing rope-a-dope in cinema
history so do you guys know about that
there was a movie called the woods that
was coming out no one gave a [ __ ] about
it cuz like we already saw the forest
then at Comic Con they were like hey
here's the woods by the way it's Blair
Witch now you know never won a comic I
was like was a [ __ ] Blair Witch
single who knew but what if this movie
sucked ass I would still love this [ __ ]
out of that Blair Witch does its part
nothing is going to recapture the
creepiness and subtlety of the original
Blair Witch Project but Blair Witch did
have its fair share of creepiness the
audio is great I love the ambiance
I love the
claustrophobic feeling of these woods it
has it's very strong familiarity to the
first one but it also has its cool stuff
I will say Blair which is definitely a
good time no alcohol required right guys
so Blair which have you seen it what did
you think about it what's your favorite
scary movie of all time whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to say more
[Music]